مبدعون عرب غيابهم الرحيل سجالات وصلت الى
اروقه المحاكم ازمات فنيه وصحيه وعائليه
اليكم ابرزها في 2022
[موسيقى]
كانت الفنانه المصريه شيرين عبد الوهاب
نجمه الازمات والانهيارات على مدار العام
2022 انصح التعبير وذلك منذ ظهورها الصادم
حديقه الراس في حفل ناحيه واواخر العام
الماضي كشف عن مشكله عميقه في علاقتها مع
الفنان حسام حبيب فصلت عنه رغم انها لا
تزال تحبه بحسب تعبيرها
احبه وعادت اليه سرا نفذ ذلك لاحقا واعلن
اذكرها له وكانت الاتهامات بحقه في اطلاله
اعلاميه اثارت الكثير من الجدل ورفعت عليه
دعوه قضائيه ثم اعلنت التنازل عنها
ومسامحتها له بعد تسويه خلافهما قضائيا
غيرت اداره اعمالها واحذيه حفل ناجحا في
قرطاج وبدات في اطاله اعلاميه بحال جيده
قبل ان تدخل ازماتها منعطف ماساويا حينما
قام شقيقها بداعها مصحا نفسيا وزعم في
اطاله اعلاميه مع والدتها انه قام بذلك
لعلاجها من ادمان المخدرات ما كثثت في
المصاحف لمده وخرجت منه بدراما جديده
اختمت باعلان عودتها رسميا لس حسام اواخر
العام
والتزمت الفنانه المصريه ياسمين صبري
الصمت حول تكرار انتشار خبر عودتها لرجل
الاعمال المصري احمد ابو هشيمه بعد اعلان
انفصالهما في النصف الاول من العام 2022
في حين المحت الفنانه المصريه ياسمين
الرئيس عبر حساباتها على مواقع التواصل
لعودتها لزوجها المخرج هذه الباجوري بعد
اشهر قليله من اعلان انفصالهما الذي تزامن
مع جدلا اثاره تصريح له في اطاله اعلاميه
قال في انه لا يمانع اداء زوجته القبل
والمشاهد الرومانسيه في اعمالها لو الدور
اللي هي لازم كده والعمل
متوظف ده
ممم
انفصلت الفنانه نسرين طافش عن طبيب
الاسنان والمعالج بالطاقه شريف شرقاوي بعد
زواج دام قرابه الخمسه اشهر
ومن الازمات العائليه الى الفنيه وكان من
اكثرها حده في العام 2022 حمله الانتقادات
التي واجهها صناع وابطال فيلم اصحاب ولا
اعز الذي عرضت نتفليكس في يناير الماضي
جاء ذلك وسطا انقسام الحاد في الاراء بين
رواد سوشيال ميديا طغى عليها الاتهام
بالخروج عن القيم المحافظه في العالم
العربي ونالت النجمه المصريه منى زكي
النصيب الاكبر من نجوم المنتقدين والذي
وصل حد الاساءه لشخصها وعائلتها كما اثار
عرض مسلسل الضاحك الباكي عن السيره
الذاتيه للفنان الراحل نجيب الريحاني
الكثير من الجدل على مواقع التواصل وفي
وسائل الاعلام المصريه اواخر العام 2022
وافضل السجال الذي طال في مصر حول مؤدل
مهرجانات خلال العامين الماضيين الى اعلان
الفنان المصري هاني شاكر استقالته من منصب
نقيب المهن الموسيقيه بعد مؤتمر عاصف اريد
منه تسويه الخلاف والصلح بين حسن شاكوش
وشعبه الايقاع
[موسيقى]
بعض الازمات الفنيه في العام 2022 بدا
بسجالات بين الفنانين على مواقع التواصل
على خلفيه اطلالات اعلاميه ووصلت لاحقا
الى اروقه المحاكم كالسيجال بين الفنانين
اللبنانيين ميريام فارس وفارس كرم الذي
استخدم فيه الاخير كلمات وصفت بالنابيه
والذكوريه بحقها والخلاف بين الفنانه
اللبنانيه اليسا من جهه والفنان زياد برجي
والشاعر الغنائي احمد ماضي من جهه اخرى
حول الملكيه الفكريه لاغنيه انا وبس التي
اصدرتها اليسا من كلمات ماضي والحام برجي
الذي اعاد اصدارها بصوته تحت عنوان وبطير
ومن السجالات والازمات الفنيه الى الاخبار
الصادمه والمثيره للجدل كاعلان النيابه
العامه في مصر احاله الفنانه منه شلبي الى
المحاكمه الجنائيه بتهمه احرازها جوهر
الحشيش المخدر بقصد تعاطي وكان قد خبض
عليها في مطار القاهره بهذه التهمه لدى
عودتها من الولايات المتحده اواخر نوفمبر
الماضي وتم الافراج عنها وقتها بكفاله
لحين استكمال التحقيقات اما المغني
العراقي سيف نبيل فقد كشف عن ازمه يواجهها
في العراق تحول دون زيارته لبلده وقال ان
السبب هو قيام البعض بتزوير مستندات
قانونيه تحمل توقيعه وبصمته ما ادى الى
اصدار امر بتوقيفه في بعض اغانيه من قناته
على يوتيوب وفي ازمه الاخرى اعلنت
الخارجيه العراقيه استخدام السفير العراقي
بالاردن حيدر العذاري والعمل على اتخاذ
الاجراءات المناسبه بحقه بعد موته
انتقادات على مواقع التواصل لمجموعه صور
نشرها الفنان اللبناني راغب علامه جماعته
بالسفير وزوجته وكالعاده كان الفنان محمد
رمضان نصيب من ازمات 2022 ومن اكثرها
اثاره للجدل انتشار صوره فتاه اسرائيليه
بين احضانه باليونان حيث احيا حفل هناك
مطلع اغسطس ما عاد الى الاذان ازمه اتهامه
بالتطبيع بسبب صورته مع المغني الاسرائيلي
عمر ادم في دبي قبل عامين كما واجه رمضان
سلسله الغاءات متتاليه لحفلات اعلن عنها
في الاسكندريه دمشق الدوحه واربيل
وفي العراق ايضا ردخت الجهه المنظمه لحفل
الفنان المغربي سعد المجرد من المحتجين
وصفات بالهستوريه والغت الحفل قبيله وقت
قصير من انطلاقته رغم نفاذ التذاكر
والاستقبال الحار لسعد في مطار العاصمه
العراقيه وبسبب اجواء التشنج الاقليمي
بحسب تعبيرها قررت المغنيه اللبنانيه هبه
طواجي بالتشاور مع فريقها ان الظروف غير
مناسبه لاقامه حفل مع المؤلف الموسيقي
اسامه الرحباني في اوبرا دمشق وذلك بعد
استكمال التحضيرات ونفاذ تذاكر الحفل
والى الا الازمات الصحيه فقد اصيب المطرب
العراقي كاظم الساهر بدوار واكمل الحفله
جالسه على كرسي خلال حفل له فيهن كما اخلق
جورج وسوف محبيه على صحته بسبب ظهوره في
حفل الموسم جده بوزن زائد ونفى سلطان
الطرب في اطاله الاعلاميه لهذا العام نيته
الاعتزال طالما لا يزال يجد نفسه قادرا
على العطاء وخضعت الفنانه المصريه انغام
لعمليه جراحيه وصفت الد ففي الكتف وبعد
عودتها لنشاطها الفني شغلت بالا محبيها
مجددا بالاعلان عن تعرضها لوعكه صحيه
طارئه تعافت منها مؤخرا
[موسيقى]
واخيرا غياب الرحيل العديد من الفنانين
والمشاهير العرب في 2022 كالمخرج السوري
الشهير بسام الملا والاعلامي المصري وائل
الابراشي والفنانين المصريين مع ابو عوف
وهشام سليم وجال فهمي وسمير صبري كما ودع
العالم العربي هذا العام صوت طفولته برحيل
الفنان اللبناني سامي كلارك ورحل المؤلف
الموسيقي اللبناني احسان المنذر بعد ما
ترك ارثا من الاغنيات الخالده في ذاكره
العالم العربي وهز الوسط الفني اللبناني
خبر الرحيل الماساوي لجورج الراسي عن عمر
39 عاما بحادث سير مروع في طريق عودته من
سوريا الى لبنان بعد ان احيا اخر حفلاته
في دمشق